es passiert nicht um 3 der kann was
komisches geräusch von der farbe kurz
nachdem der wecker geklingelt hat
einfach einer meiner tür geklingelt
heute fragen sollte lukas um eine
branche professioneller ja ich will hier
nicht mehr geld lockt in der zone main
andere kameraden reise eigentlich
zusammen was gefordert ich bin ich das
mit meiner nichte shana gefüllt haben
aber vielleicht haben wir dann hätten
das nicht tun sollen
was hier mit meiner 80 sie aus was will
ich eigentlich vermeiden weil die halt
total vettel hat nur eine kleine folgen
zu haben
wir werden gerade mit anders als
buchstadt wert noch ist wichtigste nach
einer dusche morgen ist eine schöne
radtour auch keinen bartwuchs da muss
man natürlich nicht gravierend level und
ich werden jetzt in einen baumarkt
fahren weil wenn jeder video gerade
sehen donnerstag aber und gerade
mittwoch und ich mussten wir für holz
machen
laut laser lukas gmx.de warum auch nicht
bei den eingang findet ja gerade vom
baumarkt weg wir haben eine schnur
gekauft die beiden plötzlich fünf meter
lang und werden jetzt die op wenn ihr
den block gesät ab wie das letzte video
wahrscheinlich auch schon gesehen also
wir zu hause wieder wieder draußen
angekommen ist noch im supermarkt
gegangen weil er sich noch ein paar
sachen zu sein wir einkaufen wollte ich
habe meine schnur bekommen und werde
jetzt ein bisschen nichts dazu will ich
mehr so viele kommentare von wegen
die den alltag von schillig aus und das
noch immer so lange in der union
verstehen dass ich jeden fall global und
ich bin auch nicht jeden tag an der uni
und ich mache die blockfreien thema
sammeln was cooles passiert was für euch
cooles nur den ingwer und andere
youtuber nicht irgendwo unterwegs bin
oder so zum beispiel den letzten drei
vier wochen kamen hat so gar keine blog
weil einfach nur am bett schlafen da
also ich bin jetzt mit einer
verständlichen mit 550 weiter
geschrieben aber ich muss eine terrasse
und so machen ich muss auch nicht mehr
mit mir jedenfalls bei monat also die
bachelorarbeit schreibt hat man mehr
oder weniger weil und club jahre in
sechs tagen geben aber freunde wenn
jemand von mir haben wollte
wer dann schreibt man die kommentare ich
werde nämlich ab märz nächsten jahres
glaube ich meinen master machen und dann
kann ich euch nicht alltag zeigen
händler sprachen auch nach berlin wir
buchen hotels in die steckdosen alter
belgier dessen poster wer mir gerade
video fordert er wir heute abend mit ihm
fragen werden in eine ordnung buchwerte
63 einfach bonus machen das heißt wir
sehen uns nachhaltig also nach berlin
fahren
es wird gerade drei stunden vergangen
ich habe jetzt das video fertig
geschnittene video hier habt ihr dann
wahrscheinlich jetzt an gewinn also dass
der cygnet drei weitere video gesehen
habt und euch fraglich nachdem er
gemacht habe so pflanzen fürs komische
salge an dem ich in verschiedenen jobs
gemacht
dabei habe ich hier oben mit einer
fünften das wetter freunde ist rasiert
schon krank also die 3
wieso am liebsten würde ich mich einfach
draußen auf die terrasse bachelorarbeit
schreiben
ich habe britta vor verstreichen
historiker drittel fertig so das
schwierige bei einer bachelor ist ja
nicht den ganzen inhalt zu schreiben
sondern dass literatur
ich habe aber noch einen ganz kurzen
mitteilung war er angekommen ich habe ja
gesagt hat sich eventuell bald wieder
produzieren möchte und diese hier erst
mal drauf und die linien da kann man dem
das ding gastieren dort sein handy
draufkleben ich habe den schiedsrichter
auf meinem handy welt den kopf voll
gefunden raub aber rang wieder und die
biber trautmann kanada finnland hier
draufkleben und dass die rückseite hier
liegt auf dem handy händen da kann man
den mittelfinger abnehmen oder halt auch
am handy dann hinten dran drehen gefällt
mir und maler fritz genannt mit
konkreter zwei leben wird man dein handy
machen kann also schreibt wir gerne in
die kommentare auf dem bock hätte dass
ich den job angeht sondern bitte
vielleicht morgen beim launch mit
verfügbar sein
von lukas und morgen luca problem auf
zwei artikel also jenes lang täglich
irland noch die europa league wo drauf
steht das wird auch noch morgen 50
verloren und war eine riesige dass meine
hand zu oder kann man auch als strand
becken also nachhaltigen lucas oklahoma
das büchlein führung für den lukas ott
noch wo habe ich den anti passen ihr
werdet im shop hat die möglichkeit haben
auch das bild von 500 auf zykliker
werden quasi weitergeleitet auf die
amerikanische rolle doch der verkauf
wird und ich habe ja schon gesagt hat
ich heute abend nach berlin fahren werde
und wir sind wahrscheinlich erst
mitternacht heißt ich werde mal um drei
uhr nachts heute einen fisches batterien
eventuell kennt ihr diese 83 auf youtube
die leute komisch bedingungen drei und
acht machen passieren in welche geister
ähnlichen sachen und das ist natürlich
nicht alles kate ist nicht alles nur
gestellt man mir leid zuschauer nicht
verarschen wirklich wirklich ruhe und
lächelt das passiert wirklich um drei
uhr nachts deswegen haben dessen und ich
uns heute gedacht übrigens hier in
meiner anleitung irgendwelche hosen
herum damit die luft gekühlt noch nicht
ausgedacht wer heute nacht um 3 uhr
einen bachelor in dem hotelzimmer dem
man abwarten was passiert
es sind jetzt alle wieder zwei stunden
vergangen ist gerade nach 50 grad ihrer
bachelorarbeit geschrieben meinte gerade
dass er wahrscheinlich erst um 8 uhr war
hier sein wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die polonaise abgelaufenen pflege oft
kommentare von wegen luca ist er immer
sinnvoll viel kohlenhydrate kalorien
lief das schaffst du das fit zu bleiben
immer wenn ich was gegessen habe gehe
ich dann auch meine handel banken
bisschen trainieren
so bleibt man fit zwei jahre 2000 jahre
später 2000 jahre der flachen jetzt
gerade nicht mehr das setze mich gleich
abholen sondern dass ich zu maxim und
jana drüber laufen werde ich mitmachen
video aufnehmen blablabla dann werden
wir von david banda preis ist erst mal
eine sache auf jeden fall mit luca noch
ein bisschen aber auch noch ein bisschen
luca berlin ein bisschen kälter in köln
kriegen muss ich auf jeden fall noch ein
super match mitnehmen bücher
wiederfinden und wirklich auf jeden fall
auch dem fittesten aber den wollten wir
heute nacht um 3 uhr im hotelzimmer
drehen also vielleicht doch mainz
wir müssen verkaufen
ich will auch noch boxen kaufen die
ursprüngliche zeit der velos bahn
wollten war 18 uhr jetzt gerade 20 41
battle vertrags dazu stand jetzt sind
wir so gegen drei uhr nachts in berlin
ich hoffe dass es mit dem checker noch
alles klappt kann eigentlich eine
unterlage steuerberater dabei gerade
viertel nach neun mann brauchen google
550 in berlin das heißt entgegenkommen
und grauen acht alter jetzt uns war
scheiße was passiert um drei uhr nachts
konkret kontrolliert
wir befinden uns jetzt gerade an einer
tankstelle mitten im nirgendwo wir sind
gleich in görzke oder irgendwie so hat
einer von euch auf götze kommt schaut
auf die startseite getankt jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal ich wollte auch noch
eine kleinigkeit zu essen holen gleich
noch nicht so wirklich zu abend gegessen
habe und er ist auf jeden fall eine
entspannte fahrt
wir sind gerade in berlin an dem hotel
vom markt im jahr angekommen
the project die gerade ein und ich
schreibe immer noch bei sechs stunden
bachelorarbeit gerade im auto wir sind
in unserem hotel angekommen beeilen weil
gerade irgendwie 254 oder so um 3 uhr
während fisches wieder im hotel zu
überdrehen darüber so ein übereiltes
mädchen wenn man richtig geile blondine
und würde ich glaube daran vorbei fragen
zu tun ja die ist auf jeden fall
hübschen ihn anspricht
[Musik]
gerade hier wird schon freundes ist
wirklich gerade genau 3 uhr ich habe
extra in schutz genommen und ich würde
sagen dass hier vertreten wäre los
geht's
ich hoffe ihr versteht was diese ganzen
drei und acht videos von verschiedenen
youtube kanälen einfach alles nur
verarsche videos sind es passiert nicht
um 3
der block hat mal wieder gefallen
[Musik]